well nothing breeds controversy like  halloween candy power rankings  feuds have been started and divorces  have been filed over arguments like what  is better  milky way or three musketeers it's milky  way don't be ridiculous  but in the spirit of adding sport and  spice to our sugar here is a rundown of  which nfl teams  imitate candy reese's pieces is the  unstoppable force  great with a lot of enemies and a huge  marketing base  obviously it's the chiefs the hershey  bar classic  strong championship level and really old  it is the tom brady and buccaneers of  candy the 100 grand  deceives people with its strong name and  peaked in the 90s  we're talking about the cowboys the  charleston chew  oh i forgot about you oh that's right  you do exist  just like the jaguars and the worst  option possible  terrible for your health don't let your  kids try it this is the new york jets of  halloween candy  please stay away from black licorice  we'll be right back